there's a lot of racism in this country
but it's not
the people that are being called nazis
and hitler aficionados and things of
that nature
it's it's the left the left has become
wholly racist
there there's really nothing else i can
add to that i i don't know
where any decent democrat is anymore i
even tweeted out actually yesterday i
said are there any
self-proclaimed liberals who are
non-woke who still considers themselves
democrats
because i would love to talk to them um
and
basically a bunch of people the
responses that i got i got
probably i don't know several hundred
responses the answers that i got were
mostly bill maher
and tulsi gabbard now bill maher as i've
said many times i think he's just sort
of a guilty libertarian but i would love
to talk about it with him
does he consider himself a democrat
anymore like the democrats have gone
woke so is bill maher really that if the
main thing that he fights
is the woke stuff which it seems to be
so i don't know if he's a democrat
as for tulsi i obviously i'm friends
with halsey and i've had her on the show
i would love to discuss this further
does she at this point still
consider herself a democrat i mean tulsi
actually issued a tweet last week when
racist
mayor of chicago lori lightfoot said she
would only be interviewed
by black or brown people tulsi told the
truth on twitter she
called it out as anti-white racism
so i don't know if she can consider
herself part of that party
anymore i don't know i would love to
discuss with her a few other names that
came up were brett weinstein
sam harris christina hoff sommers i
don't know that any of them consider
themselves democrats i know they don't
consider themselves conservatives but my
argument
would be that we're all conservatives
right now if you want to conserve
anything
decent that america has put forth in
these last 250 years
in any event to prove my point further
um
chris ruffo who is one of the great
advocates fighting against critical race
theory in all the schools
he is bringing lawsuits in state by
state and we're seeing
now states fighting against critical
race theory
in schools which is phenomenal by the
way you don't want a horrifically toxic
dishonest set of ideas that teaches you
that your skin color is the most
important thing about you
the thing that you should either be the
most proud of or most ashamed of you
don't want
to be teaching this to kids and yet we
have done it and now we see it has burst
forth into everything in terms of
our political discourse and cultural and
everything else but anyway
chris ruffo went on mark lamont
hill's show on black it's called black
news tonight
and listen to this exchange and you tell
me
who the racist is if i were to ask you
what particularly if you're saying
whiteness is a thing that
is being constructed as negative and
shouldn't be name name something
positive that you like about being white
well
sure i you know i'll i'll answer with uh
with that a thing there
there's a lot of documents that are
floating around public schools that say
things like
uh timeliness showing up on time is a
white supremacist value or a white value
white dominant value things like
rationality things like the
enlightenment things like
uh you know uh objectivity and uh
these are very strange things to be
ascribed to a racial identity my view is
that these are actually
should be ascribed to every individual
human being every individual human being
regardless of whatever racial category
we impose on them
name something positive about being that
you believe is positive about being
white
again i don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
blackness i think that's wrong i think
we should look at people as individuals
i think we should celebrate
uh different people's accomplishments
and uh again i think the idea you you
mentioned ignatia if native says the
goal is to quote
abolish the white race um in any other
context this would be interpreted as a
near
genocidal slur i don't buy into it the
reason i'm not going to answer your
question
is i reject that categorization i think
of myself as an individual human being
with my own capabilities and i would
hope that we could both judge each other
as individuals
and come to common values on that basis
bravo chris ruffo you've got a fan
and dave rubin who who is the racist in
that conversation who is trying to
racialize everything and who's trying to
de-racialize everything
as rufo repeatedly points out he wants
people
to be treated as individuals so he
doesn't even buy into the argument
but mark lamont hill is playing a very
dangerous game right there implying
that if you are for things like working
hard
in essence and if you are uh you know
you're willing to be on time and all of
the things that rufo has talked about
that are baked into critical race theory
that these are somehow white supremacist
ideas so he's telling him well tell me
something good about being white
except chris is saying these these
things are not about being white
they're about being a decent human being
these are the things that bring us all
together that make humanity flourish and
everything else
so there's one person racializing and
then one person
deracializing and yet if you were to
listen to the mainstream narrative
they would get who's the racist
backwards roofo followed up
on twitter and he wrote this the
solution reject
the premise of race essentialism in all
its forms
stop using crude racial labels and
pejoratives
to demonize individuals mark follows the
critical race theory playbook
lump your enemies into crude identity
categories load those categories with
negative connotations
enforce a taboo against expressing
positive traits
and use guilt and shame to manipulate
individuals into your political cult
don't take the bait i love
the clarity from chris ruffo right there
they are playing a game where when when
lamont hill when he
says tell me something good about being
white it's a false
question goodness and hard work and
decency
and not judging people based on the
color skin is not inherently
white these are enlightenment values not
they're beyond enlightenment values
these are
these are values these are i would say
biblical values these are
values that that the greek philosophers
taught us that had nothing to do
with skin color now we have a movement
where they're trying to make everything
about skin color
so okay so marklemont hill on
black news tonight i've never seen the
show before that that's fine but
remember if he had called it white news
tonight everybody would go in
bananas right we just we just absolutely
know this
but what we've seen is that the left is
the one that is racializing everything
so if you don't
believe me we've talked about this
before but the left is
literally the democrats in a completely
partisan vote
decided to stop
schools well you know what i'm going to
read you the quote from fox because this
will just it'll just get to it right
there
this is from fox news senate democrats
blocked an amendment
to the new covet 19 hate crimes act that
would have barred universities that
discriminate
against asian americans from accessing
federal funding
senators ted cruz from texas and john
kennedy from louisiana
co-sponsored the unsuccessful amendment
which would have banned federal funding
from going to colleges and universities
that discriminate
against asian american applicants when
being recruited
by schools or applying i'll give you a
quote from cruz and kennedy themselves
despite their calls to end racism it is
clear democrats are only paying lip
service to fighting discrimination
against asian americans and will allow
targeted discrimination
against them to continue at america's
universities
and colleges so if you're not clear on
what happened here
in a completely partisan vote the
democrat senators decided to take
out a line from this bill that was
saying you cannot at universities
discriminate against
asians so it's not just that say the the
cultural
elite or whatever you would consider
someone like mark lamont hill
the the the lefty thinkers in the
internet space
are being racist it is that the
democratic
party is racist please please
somebody show me where the republicans
have passed a bill that has been nearly
that racist
now i know people might say but wait a
minute what about those those voting
bills in georgia
where they didn't want people to get
water on lines while they're voting
there's nothing racist about it there's
nothing racist about it and by the way
there's nothing racist
about having to have an id and if you
think minorities can't get an id you're
probably racist are you telling me the
average black person can't get on a
plane i'm fairly certain they can
can they go buy a six pack of beer i'm
fairly certain they can and by the way
i've heard a million people on the right
say this
if you could actually prove that there
is some
subset of people that cannot get ids
because of race or for any other reason
me
despite all my libertarian leanings i
would be for the government using
some money to literally bring these
people
to a place where they could take a
picture and get an id and you know when
i had nikki haley on who of course the
former
governor of south carolina she talked
about how she did just that as the
governor of south carolina they said to
they're all of the citizens they said if
you cannot get an id
for whatever reason it is we will help
you get it they did this big program and
i don't remember the exact number we'd
have to go back into the interview and
check it
but basically it was like a dozen people
showed up i think it was 15 was it
15-ish i think that's what she said yeah
15-ish
people showed up to take advantage of
this so they racialize
everything and just lie about what it is
that
republicans are doing it's just
extraordinary